go where your curiosity leads you pay no
attention to what people are saying is
or is not good science if you are
curious and you want to understand
something follow your nose and go where
your curiosity leads that's the only
thing I can say all of the very very
good theoretical physicists that I know
have done exactly that what did Stephen
mean to you personally as a foil he
wasn't the easiest person to get along
with I remember hearing that from many
people uh but um but he had this magical
captivating effect on all of science so
much so that if you asked any person
who's the most famous scientist they
would say someone like Stephen Hawking
not me yeah well there were many aspects
of Steph Hawking first of all he was a
great physicist there's no question of
that uh maybe it was a little bit of a
stretch to say that he was Einstein or
Newton but he was a very very very
important influence in physics uh but
you know there were other aspects to him
that uh that certainly caught people's
imagination his stubbornness against uh
against what over overwhelming
ARS how he managed to to not just
survive but to flourish and to do great
physics when he could barely move no
more than his
eyelash this is an incredible story so
he was in addition to being a great
physicist and a hero to physicist
because of his physics
he was a gigantic hero in a in a much
bigger sense that being said he could
frustrate me he could annoy me he could
anger me but not because of Any
personality glitch but because I was
very
frustrated by um by let me call it his
incredible stubbornness not to recognize
the to to my mind not to recognize the
importance of his own work in a sense he
had asked an extremely deep question a
question that uh that has dominated
theoretical physics ever since the uh
for you know for 30 40 years
now but I felt he had taken the easy
route and tried to find an easy answer
when the answer was far more subtle and
complex
um his recognition of the question was
Monumental his answer was probably not
uh his answer was information is lost in
black holes that seemed wrong and I
wanted Stephen very much to realize that
his question would lead to something
much deeper than what he uh than what he
had envisioned so he was that's right he
was a very complicated man very complex
and interesting for sure the problem was
it was hard to communicate with him just
because of physically hard to
communicate with I remember once seeing
him speak at a Royal Society meeting
that I had somehow uh stolen someone's
invitation to attend and Stephen was
there at the guest and it was 1996 or so
and someone asked him a question and
this is when he could still move his
finger so he said um they asked him why
did you write A Brief History of Time
it's rumored that no one understands the
entirety of this book and no one's even
read it and Stephen answered in his
inimitable uh synthesized voice I did
wrote it because my daughter needed to
go to college and his sense of humor
comes across of course your books are
known for their Clarity uh but not for
their dumbing down I actually uh learned
quite a great deal not that it's like
some great encomium to hear from some
nobody like Brian keing that he
benefited and profited greatly from your
book but some of the topics that you
talk about are more relevant than ever
uh nine years after its publication and
I want to ask you in the intervening
nine years since you wrote the book what
has changed what would you write
differently if you were to write this
book again other than lamenting the loss
of your of your friend and and rival in
a in a in a friendly way Stephen Hawking
actually I think I wouldn't write
anything different I think I would write
almost exactly the same thing but the
difference would be that I would have
written another book right afterward on
the followup of what happened afterwards
in the last when did I write that book
2005 something like that is now let's
see if I can do the arithmetic 15 years
later
mhm uh the subject is the subject and
the subject means the subject of the
quantum mechanics of gravity that
subject has not only expanded but it's
been
clarified uh not more than clarified
almost
revolutionized by new ideas ideas that I
did write about in that book but which
have developed
extraordinarily surprising directions so
I don't think I would have changed what
I wrote in that book I would have wrun
another book
afterwards but I don't know if I have
the I don't know if I have the endurance
to do uh to do it yeah I mean when we
think about books so your most famous
paper I looked up you know citations I
forget what it is it's several hundred
to thousand citations this book and your
other book uh the Cosmic Landscape I
think uh that book sold tens of tens and
tens of thousands of of copies what's
the difference when you write a popular
a book for a popular audience that has a
lot of red meat sorry to My Vegan fans
uh but uh versus writing you know a
paper which might be read by a few
thousand nerds at most and maybe not
even all the way through versus your
book writing for the popular audience
that's consumed rapidly by hundreds of
thousands of people well first of all
I've always gotten a lot of not just
pleasure but I think more than pleasure
out of explaining things I like to
explain things and there are at least
two reasons why I enjoy explaining
things so much first of all I'm a ham
and I really get a kick out of showing
people how clever I am and how easily I
can explain things which sound hard so
that's uh that's one aspect of it but
the other thing which is very important
is the process of
explaining for me teaches me a great
deal about the subject I'm explaining
and the more I try to explain it to a
less and less technical audience the
more I learn new ways to think about
things so it's an important part of my
own physics the process in my own head
what goes on in my head when I try to
explain things on the other hand the
business of writing a book like the
black hole War gave me an opportunity to
try out something that I'd never tried
out before that was to write about
people to write about myself when I
write a physics paper I don't write
about
myself and if the paper happens to have
um reference to stepen Hawking or
somebody else I don't write about them I
write about their
equations this was something I had
always wanted to try my hand as a writer
and see if I could both write a little
bit about myself about the people I knew
the uh the whole
human aspect of uh theoretical physics
and I found I found surprisingly much to
my surprise that I had some ability to
do it yeah I had a terrible I had a
terrible uh time as a student as a young
student with my English uh
classes I was always considered a very
poor English uh student I don't know why
that was you talk about you know having
a little bit of a of a maybe it was a a
complex but maybe it was more of a chip
on your shoulder and I see you as you
know one of you're a brawler you're
you're one of these tough you know New
York Jews I I hate to keep bringing up
our our common background but but the
point is I think you I I characterize
you as Fearless I don't think that
you're you know infallible but I feel
like you're Fearless and I wonder if
that modest upbringing you had with with
parent your parents didn't go to college
right no no no my father got through the
fifth grade my mother I think got
through the 10th grade and now you're a
member of the National Academy of
Sciences what does that feel like did
you ever have what we call impostor
syndrome in Academia I don't think I
felt I was an imposter because I felt I
wasn't talented but um you know I came
from this very working class background
my my formative years up to the age of
about
22 most of the people I knew were very
workingclass my father and his plumber
friends I was a plumber for a while uh
and ccny was not a place where you got
the the Harvard what shall I call it
patina uh it was full of workingclass
kids like myself we didn't live on
campus we uh we took the subway to
school so so when I finally got to
graduate school I felt very out of place
people were extremely kind to me at the
at
Cornell they felt I had talent and they
were extremely kind to me but I felt out
of place I felt I was in a world that I
didn't uh that I didn't come
from and um felt awkward in it and I I
don't know if I felt I was an impostor
but I did feel very much an outsider and
I did wonder do I really have as much
talent as I hope I have and the just ify
how nice people were to me so yeah and I
think that lasted a long long
time and I felt like an outsider until I
suddenly discovered I was the ultimate
Insider in the subject how do you mean
the ultimate Insider I mean well I began
to discover that half the population of
theoretical physics had been my students
or my proo and my uh all my close
friends and um I also began to feel much
more comfortable in the academic
world uh
just probably because people listened to
me people tended to accept what I
said I think I was probably 50 before I
began to feel comfortable in the
academic world and that was long after
you were at Stanford right I mean this
is long after I was at Stanford yeah I
went to Stanford when I was 37 38 and uh
to what do you what do you attrib what
would you recommend to somebody younger
person now not quite 50 who still
struggles with this who has uh kind of
this alternating view of himself or
herself as as talented as curious what
what's the test what's the metric that
someone can use to keep encouraging them
to go on so maybe I won't give any
advice about how to get out of that
predicament but maybe I will give some
thoughts about how to use that
predicament yeah very likely my own
sense of I won't say inadequacy I didn't
feel inadequate my own sense of
discomfort
probably to some extent may have led me
to to be more independent more
um uh and to push harder on ideas uh
maybe I just wanted to succeed because
uh because I did have this feeling of um
outsiderness so I would say just
whatever your whatever your
um
uh what's the right word whatever your
sense of not belonging or whatever it is
use it you probably can't get rid of it
that easily find a way to use it and you
even had encounters on the you know
sacred grounds of of Cambridge and
Oxford and utre and all these places
that you recount the book is an
adventure story I kind of think of you
it's a cliche but you know the Indiana
Jones of theoretical physics I do feel
like uh Sigman Freud once said something
to the effect that you know a man who is
loved by his father and mother uh in
some sens is like destined for greatness
and it applies to women too do your
parents give you confidence I mean you
weren't raised Jewish what was your you
know parents ra Jewish I was I mean you
were raised Jewish but you weren't
you're not believer now so what was your
no no wait I wasn't raised religious
yeah be be be careful I mean I was I was
raised quite Jewish out of a different
tradition the tradition was Jewish
leftism leftism uh coming uh from before
before there was the Soviet Union my
parent my parents my my parents my
grandparents came out of Eastern Europe
at the time of the
Zar and they were leftists they were all
leftists they were not
religious I suspect my father's family
were atheists but uh they
were and that's the that's what I grew
up in but it was very Jewish what it
wasn't was religious and when you meet
people as you talk about in the book
ranging from Fineman to uh to to you
know obviously stepen Hawking had the
use of none of his you know real
physical faculties but he kind of
depended as much on his mental acuity
and uh and so forth you talk a little
bit about being disappointed recently
you know that maybe he didn't take it as
seriously as he should have I mean he
was known for these bets I always found
that you know there was a famous signed
wager outside of in Bridge Hall at
Caltech where I was a postto after
getting fired from Stanford we'll talk
about that some other day um but uh but
that you know poster of the bet with Kip
Thorne which Kip Thorne had to concede
uh because uh and I think it was over
like a a subscription to Playboy or
something like that but Stephen was this
Mercurial figure and and I wonder you
know you talk about how yeah it was
almost like a feeling of frustration
like you want that competition you
thrive on the kind of battling and the
resistance that we get from our
colleagues and I wonder you know if
we've lost that I mean you're you're you
know closer to to you know to um you
know the the the the the interaction
with Stephen than I ever was I just met
him that one time but when you think
about um you know physics today is it
has it changed you know for the better
or for the worse in terms of the
conflict that we now see moved to social
media Twitter I know you're not on that
which is why you're so
productive uh so nowadays we see like
these battles like today there's a
battle about life on Venus you know and
it's being waged on Twitter what do you
make of that compared to your battles in
person ter it's terrible it's terrible
um okay life on Venus um the the war or
over not only I don't mean the black
hole War I mean what is a much nastier
War over where the string theory is is a
contribution to science or a
contribution to
anti-science that takes place on the
Blogger sphere and I do from time to
time read some of it I think is very
very destructive how is it destructive
it it's foolish it's silly largely the
people people don't know what the hell
they're talking about and especially if
you read the commentary that comes after
the uh the things that the blogers says
they can be
imbecilic they can truly be
imbecilic but what does it do what does
its net effect I think it adds to the um
to the sense that you can't trust
scientists now scientists are not always
right they're but they do try there's
very very little in in my experience
there is very very little dishonesty in
the science that I think I am involved
in maybe no dishonesty or they can't say
none but very very
little and when you read these blogs you
would think that every string theorist
is doing what he's doing only to be able
to get more money from the
NSF this is utter BS and so I said I
think it's dangerous I think it's
dangerous and I think it's counter dtive
that I damn well wish it would go away
my thumb is very busy right now holding
up good old Albert but if yours is free
please go ahead and hit that like button
and don't forget to subscribe it really
helps us with the algorithm I know you
sure you know Paul steinhardt my friend
at Princeton University feels the same
way and he actually feels it's even more
invidious than as you recount because as
you know sometimes you have tentative
ideas as I'm an experiment I'm just a
simple experimentalist closer to a
plumber uh than you ever are nowadays
okay that's such a misconception but
okay I'm just kidding uh you know Jim
Simons once told me a joke about
plumbers he said he had a call a plumber
once and uh the plumber came to his
house early in the morning to fix some
leaky toilet and Jim asked him how much
do I owe you and he said
$800 and the and the plumber and Jim
Simon said what are you talking about
$800 you're only here for 15 minutes you
know I I don't make even I am a hedge
fund manager I don't make $3,200 an hour
and uh oh yes he does and then that but
no then the plumers says you make $3,200
an hour hm that's what I used to make
when I was a hedge fund manager but
getting back to it uh Paul Steiner would
say is that sometimes you have these
tentative ideas as a theorist again I'm
relying on your experience not mine and
they're not ready for fully being vetted
because you need to ruminate marinate
them in your mind uh but with social
media now this gets leaked out and you
you're giving a talk and someone takes a
picture posted online and and then you
can be ridiculed so I agree I think it
is very pernicious um uh and I wonder
you know if if it's if it's irreversible
is it like a ratchet it's not going to
go back what do you think things come
and go and I don't that that's something
I can't predict and since I'm not
particularly a social media person I I
probably see less of it than most people
but I do see some of it and it it
irritates me to no end um yeah it
probably won't go away now it has very
little effect on the physicist
themselves and what they do none
whatever I would say but uh I think it
has has an effect on the public that
people tend to trust Science And
scientists less because of it yeah I
know I I I look at it um I'm always
amused when someone says trust scientist
um I don't know a scientist who just
trust scientists without a reservation
of course subject matter experts should
be listened to but I think blindly
obeying you know just because someone's
a scientist I mean look there's a lot of
misinformation that masquerades a
science as well that's that's absolutely
true how did you react to the um uh not
only to the event horizon image of the
Event Horizon of a black hole um but
also the uh the Nobel Prize to Andrea gz
and to um Reinhardt gendel for the
discovery of a compact object they went
another way not to say it was a black
hole but a a compact object what does
that data feel like when you look at it
I don't look at
it look I'm not in the least bit amazed
at this point at this point in history
that there are black holes out there of
course there are black holes out there
we've known that for a long time that's
not the point what I am amazed at is two
things first of all the ability of the
human mind to have even created the IDE
not they didn't create the idea absorbed
the idea understood the idea the whole
idea that uh that a couple of pounds of
gray flesh could have uh could have
conceived of understood and uh developed
the ideas of General relativity and all
that sort of stuff is amazing and it's
more than amazing it's uh
otherworldly and on top of that the
ability of observers and experimenters
to be able to figure out how to actually
observe and do those things and the
subtle subtle technology that went into
it which I don't know a great deal about
but I can conceive of it is really off
scale so I would say this particular
thing was a great Triumph
of observation and experimental
physics being able to see something
which is
extraordinarily difficult to have
conceived and uh built the machines and
the uh the apparatuses which was so
subtle and so fine that they were able
to see something so hard that we that
when I was a young physicist we couldn't
conceive of being able to observe a
black
hole so it is a Triumph it's a Triumph
of theory but it's even more so this
particular thing that you're talking
about a Triumph of experimental science
yeah I wonder uh this because I don't
very often get a chance to talk to uh
folks like you uh although I do have
some great guests on the show again
reminder tomorrow Shelley glashow C and
vafa and John presal is coming up these
are all characters in the black Hall war
and they're very much real non-fictional
characters I ask all of them I ask Roger
pen this too I said um you know part of
the citation or part of the recognition
that you receive this you know golden
this is a my guilt version of the Nobel
Prize that I got when I was at the Nobel
Museum 10 years ago uh but the part of
the part of the you know motivation is
you're work on singularities and I asked
him um why should we think there's a
singularity I always have an issue with
this it's almost like these snakes that
you talk about the uro buros the snake
that eats its tail we say that we need a
singularity because quantum mechanics
you know is not well understood in the
vicinity or sorry gravity is not
understood at the quantum mechanical
scale everything in the forward
Direction heads towards a singularity we
talk about the big bang and the Big Bang
being a singularity um you know Hawking
Penrose Hawking hardle um we talk about
these things but it seems like you need
to justify quantum gravity because there
could be these two regimes that are in
principle unobservable namely the core
of a black hole and the beginning of the
universe to what extent would you bet
your neighbors pet feris life on the
existence of a singularity do you think
they really
exist about the cosmic Singularity at
the beginning of the universe I don't
know and I'm somewhat suspicious I think
a singularity in the sense that in that
sense uh we simply don't
know the and the uh The Singularity
inside a black hole what the S what the
singularity means is it doesn't
necessarily mean a mathematical
Singularity what it means is the place
where things get so dense and so hot and
so um dense I guess is the word that the
laws of physics as we know them break
down or at least were the classical laws
that went into general relativity
breakdown and so we can't really we
don't really know what happens there but
but what I would say is this up till now
far more interesting than the
singularity has been the horiz Horizon
of a black hole The Horizon of the black
hole is as quantum mechanical in its own
right as a singularity
itself uh and the Horizon of the black
hole is observable that is what we
observe when we see the black hole well
I mean technically we're seeing the
light shadow in the event horizon
telescope right it's a little different
than the than the stret it's certainly
not the stretched Horizon which is no
we're not we don't directly see
radiation Hawking rad the only thing
that comes out of of the Horizon is
hawking radiation we don't see that
that's correct what we see though you
see a black disc the black dis and
around the black dis you see these rings
of light those are rings of Light which
have been focused by the gravity of the
of the black hole the black disc itself
the radius of the black disc is not
something that has to do with a
singularity it's something that has to
do with the
Horizon that uh that black disc if you
like is um its size its properties are
the Horizon now if you could see really
clearly and in a sense the um the
gravitational wave detectors do see
fairly clearly what happens to the
Horizon when it's perturbed how is it
perturbed it's perturbed by another
black hole crashing into
it and when you hear the ringing noise
and the sound that's produced by these
two not the sound but the uh the
gravitational radiation coming from it
that is pretty much direct observation
of the Horizon of the black hole so at
the same time that you were engaging
when the first opening Skirmish between
you and Stephen Hawking took place in
1981 Stephen remarkably I think that was
when he was at this Newfield uh
Symposium around the same time with
steinhardt and and uh and others and
they were debating the nature of
inflation and I wonder just before we
leave uh the notion of the reality of
singularities I wonder you know if God
you know I know who you don't believe in
um uh if God handed you a letter and
said the Big Bang is actually like Roger
Penrose uh thinks it was it's this
conformal cyclic cosmology that goes on
Eon after Eon we'll get into that later
there in other words there was no big
bang Singularity um what would that do
to your basy and priors about the
physical existence of a singularity I I
understand what you said about
mathematics but the physical existence
of it would that decrease your
credibility or very specific we're
talking about about this oscillating
version of uh that both Paul steinhardt
and Roger Penrose have advocated I would
say God why did you violate your own
laws of physics you have violated the
second law of
Thermodynamics even you can't do
that if you did do it if you did do it I
will never trust you again the second
law the second law of Thermodynamics is
one of the most fun fundamental logical
laws of physics I don't believe you so
it's sacred of course that's what led
Roger to his you know claim that the
entropy is is so improbably low yeah
yeah that's fine that was fine okay but
this idea of this universe which is
pulsing no that's a perpetual motion
machine that violates the laws of
thermodynamics and boy those are the
ones that I don't I don't I don't like I
don't okay so God talking I know well
don't you do that God I'm his surrogate
I'm his Prophet the Novi the Novi Brian
keig um I want to say uh yes so it is
true that that Paul has this um this
special contrivance and and actually
we've debated that he and I uh but
Paul's model uh doesn't depend on a
perpetual motion it depends no Paul's
model is a perpetual motion machine I
have explained that to an endless number
of times he agrees with me by the time
we'll finish the discussion and then he
goes on to say it again now now let's go
on to something else because this will
become a Perpetual emotion okay fair
enough I don't want to I don't want to
continue this I know okay all right I'll
move on so we talk about uh you know
this this notion of um of of when we
look at something uh the black hole
Singularity gets all the media attention
but it's actually the stretched Horizon
that bet twixes you talk more about why
what was that like first of all Lenny
because I'll never get to do this what
does it feel like to make a discovery
like that on a on a personal level let's
get personal don't you know I don't I I
I can understand the mathematics but
what does it feel like to make a
discovery like that and why is it so
much more important or as important as
the singularity which gets everybody's
attention I made a number of discoveries
in my career probably the first one was
the discovery of string theory or yeah
okay the uh and it's probably the most
famous one in the sense um well it's
very
exhilarating it's also
nerve-wracking uh because you're hoping
very much that nobody else out there has
made made the discovery and that you're
alone that you're the one who has
discovered it first and you don't know
that for sure somebody might be right
behind you or right in front of you uh
very much that happened exactly with
string theory with me I discovered
shortly afterwards after this enormous
exhilarating feeling of having
discovered something that nobody else
knows that somebody else did know it
nembo the great physicist nembo had
written it just exactly the same time
maybe within a day discovered exactly
the same thing and so that was a bit of
a letdown on the other hand at the same
time I felt wow I had done something
that the great nambo had
done and uh so yeah it's it's
nerve-wracking it's
exhilarating it uh you want to get it
out as fast as you can because you want
to late with it you don't want to get
scoop uh
and um that's the way it feels so maybe
we will get you on Twitter Lenny no you
won't you won't get scooped ever no you
won't now now the stretch the stretched
Horizon is as fascinating as a singular
okay the idea that
the first of all there was an old idea a
very nice idea that was due I'm trying
to remember exactly it was a French um
relativist and I know him quite well and
I can't remember his name of oh uh tibbo
deore tibo Dore and followed by Kip
Thorne and other people who are General
relativists had put forward this idea of
they called it a stretched Horizon it
wasn't me they but they had a slightly
different meaning they had the stretched
Horizon was something that could sit
outside the Horizon but it wasn't
physical it was just an arbitrary
mathematical surface that you put around
the black hole which was just there for
mathematical bookkeeping reasons and
they had worked out a whole theory of
the behavior of black
holes based on this stretched Horizon
idea what I think my contribution was to
say yes if the the stretched Horizon is
real it's a real place just above the
Horizon of a black hole where quantum
mechanics becomes truly important where
the uh the temperature of a thermometer
that you would lower down into the black
hole would become enormously large that
there was a real a genuine real place
just above the Horizon of the black hole
which in which all the information that
falls in onto the black hole
resides where it sits there it boils and
eventually boils off little bits that we
call Hawking
radiation that was that in itself was
not really really a new it really wasn't
a new discovery and um what was the new
idea was that could coexist with the
idea that somebody who falls through the
Horizon will not see that somebody doing
measurements from above the Horizon
let's say in a orbit orbiting space
station around the black hole can send
down probes long wires with the with
thermometers attached to them p them
back up and get records of what they saw
they would discover this stretched
Horizon extremely hot extremely um
complex degrees of freedom and at the
same time somebody who just fell into
the black hole would not see any such
thing this was called black hole
complimentarity complimentarity of two
descriptions and that was that it was
that which was really the the
Revolutionary radical idea what would
happen how my gu gu is one of my um uh
members in the chat room subscribers is
asking what would happen if you
performed a bell test of kind of Bell's
inequality test near the Horizon what
what would change about violation of
Bell's inequalities if anything nothing
now you know there's various things you
could do you could sit outside the
Horizon and uh do a bell experiment on
two electrons outside the Horizon both
of them outside the
Horizon and in that case nothing it
would just be the same as doing it
anywhere else more interesting
possibility is you drop one electron
into the black hole and the other one
you leave on the outside and then you
can ask can you do a bell experiment in
which the two things which are entangled
are the electron on the outside and the
entire black
hole and the answer is yes in principle
you could do a bell experiment in which
one of the subsystems was the electron
and the other subsystem was the black
hole which had
absorbed the
electron so yeah B Bell inequality
experiments in principle would work
whether they were
done uh either
way
so however I would have to say I would
have to say that Stephen Hawking would
have denied that how so he would oh he
would have said that the electron which
fell into the black
hole all of its information its Quantum
information was lost and so the one
which remained outside would not remain
entangled with
anything ah okay so he would deny this
yeah complimentarity in the end he uh he
conceded but uh I love the story in the
book uh that you write you in the middle
of this very serious I mean it's a
popular science book Lenny's personality
comes across but all of a sudden there's
a story of this medieval Kingdom and the
narrator I listen to the audio version
as well as is reading it he got this
magical voice about these pows and blah
um I I want to recommend it it's not
just for nerds like me it's it's for
geeks and dweebs everywhere um getting a
very technical question I know you're
still in your pajamas Lenny um what the
very technical question you might need
your whiteboard for this one what are
your hobbies outside of physics I don't
have any anymore you know I can't run
anymore I can't do athletics anymore I'm
too old for that uh I read a lot I read
and I read for fun do you read
whatever my wife tells me is good so
non-fiction fiction so she you're not
going to be reading losing the Nobel
Prize mostly fiction mostly fiction but
I do intend I do intend the next thing I
will read of that my wife will have me
read i i i a lot of my reading is to
read to my wife not because she can't
read she can read perfectly well but we
do enjoy reading
together uh right now we're reading a
sort of Adventure book called The Eyes
of Venice by an Italian author whose
name I can't
remember
uh it's it's quite good yeah but I
suspect the next thing we'll probably
read when we finish this thing is Barack
Barack Obama's new book his fourth
Memoir I I hope to someday be worthy of
writing you know at least three Memoirs
but I I don't think he writes well and
he writes well enough he writes well
enough and this is hard he writes well
enough that it's fun to read out loud to
each other I love the Audi book versions
of his books he's uh you know one
non-science guest that I'm uh I'm trying
to book on the into the impossible show
after you Lenny um so let's get back to
some of the stuff you brought up you are
recognized uh because Wikipedia The
repository of all wisdom and knowledge
of humanity is uh says that you are one
of the fathers if not the father of
string theory of course we talked about
the inaccessibility or lack thereof of
testing the existence of a singularity
or maybe an alternative to the big bang
I want to ask you on what grounds should
a theory be a prised uh your friend
Murray GMA Gilman used to say you should
have a rubric a metric that counts how
many correct predictions the theory
makes and subtract the number of
incorrect predictions that and that
should be on every theorist farhead
should be a mark of of this this metric
what happens I mean I'm not a papist I I
don't I don't believe in this
demarcation that only papzi what's that
a paparazzi that's right uh so the
paparazzi theorem just for those that
may not know is that only something that
can be falsified counts as true science
and I wonder in my opinion that's always
stemmed from you know Freud had penis
envy you know that some people had penis
envy I think that physicists have
mathematician Envy because a
mathematician can prove what is not
provable or can show via girdle what is
are the limits of a computational system
or mathematical system but in the LI in
math in physics we don't have such a
thing so what should we use in instead
to gauge whether or not I should send my
you know my son or daughter on an
adventure in string theory for example
well okay so basically Murray was right
of course Murray was right Murray was
always right if you didn't believe him
just ask him it's funny you say that
because the Roger used to say um it
doesn't matter if you disagree or agree
with Hawking you're on his side because
he would take different the same side
different sides of the same phys go on
sorry so was right you uh the business
is to make predictions and uh and to
test them out and see if they work and
if your theory agrees with the
predictions then it's good if it doesn't
then it's bad the problem is that it's
in the nature of the subject that the
easy things get done first the things
which take the shortest amount of time
to experimentally verify are the things
which will be done first that's almost a
tarology that you do the things first
that you can do things have gotten
harder uh experiments get harder now to
test to test uh physics at the scale of
10-7 CM uh it takes basically a
scientific lifetime to build a giant
accelerator to build the giant detectors
and so forth and that's just scratching
the surface the things that we're
interested in are far more remote than
that so I think it's sort of unfair to
use the same
criteria that we would use in the old
days where Faraday could test his
electromagnetic ideas on his bench in
his laboratory and uh
in 1850 or whatever it was you can't use
the same uh for for those kind of
questions however as far as String
Theory goes remember String Theory
initially was a theory of protons and
neutrons and
mesons there it has been tested and it's
been tested
successfully it's been tested
successfully there are no predictions of
string theory which
didn't conform to what we know about the
hadrons and we know that they behave
like strings there is no doubt about
that at all it's when it's translated
into a theory of gravity and very very
distant
physics that there are still some basic
predictions one of the basic predictions
is the existence of
gravity
uh
but I would say that it's going to take
a time it's going to take a lot of
effort
and it is not something that's going to
happen
overnight and it's not I don't know how
long it's going to take it may take 500
years before we have experimental direct
proof my guess is long before that we
will understand enough Theory enough
Theory to be quite
convinced that it is a likely
description of Elementary particles that
it's a likely description of
cosmology but the the the actual value
of it at the present time is different
than that the actual value of it is it's
the precise version of string theory is
highly consistent mathematical structure
that contains both gravitation and
quantum
mechanics and is an existence proof that
quantum mechanics and gravity can fit
together
consistently that they can and do fit
together consistently that's not a small
accomplishment right um it absolutely is
this obviously tremendous accomplishment
and it it's so successful that so many
people have um I don't want to say uh
you know attacked it but but many people
are now saying you know it's been 40 50
years since an original idea like string
theory came out a whole two or three
generations of theoretical physicists
have spent time on it uh there's no
evidence for super symmetry as yet found
at the LHC um what do you do or what do
you say because I I never have seen you
I've seen you as the most optimistic
pessimist that I know I think you are
optimistic uh in some ways but mostly
you're a realist and you're thinking um
you know you're advising a young Lenny
uh and going going you know back to
graduate school would it be in something
like this or would it be in technology
what would you advise somebody uh before
we turn to the question of of the
necessity of theories of everything in
general what would you advise young
Leonard as the TV show well first of all
I'm not in the business of giving advice
and when I get it at least 25 emails a
week or more people asking me for advice
how to become a great physicist or how
to convince my parents I ought to be a
physicist or what or
whatnot and uh for the most part I I
tend to try to answer some of them and
not all of them uh look I can't give you
advice I don't know what to tell you um
but if I you know what I would what the
advice I would have given myself which
would have been good advice for
me is just follow your curiosity
go where your curiosity leads you pay no
attention to what people are saying is
or is not good science pay no attention
to the poppers and the uh and whoever
else I won't mention names who try to
tell you what good science is if you are
curious and you want to understand
something follow your Nos and go where
your curiosity leads that's the only
thing I can say I would say that
uh to myself and I think I would
probably say it to my
students and more than that I would I
would think that all of the very very
good theoretical physicists that I know
have done exactly that and what do you
make of this proliferation of new
theories of everything that attempt to
maybe reconcile uh different approaches
to the issue of of unification of
gravity with the other three lower
energetic forces we have geomet Unity
proposed by Eric Weinstein we have this
E8 monster group exceptional Group by
Garrett Ley we have uh we have Stephen
Wolfram who's been on the show as well
uh discussing his physics project why
are there so many theories of everything
shouldn't there be only one well I don't
know that there should only be one I
mean there is there was some reality out
there and there may be many there may be
more than
one uh description of it of course those
descriptions will have to be equivalent
but they may look
different um you know there are many
versions of classical mechanics they are
all consistent with each other there's f
equals ma there's Lans and hamiltonians
and plusone brackets and they're all
they all look different but they are all
equivalent so that there should only be
one and and one may find one may find
that these different things that are
being proposed all do wind up being in
some
way uh identical descriptions however
the particular ones that you've
mentioned either I don't know much about
because I haven't read about them or I
think they are probably silly right or
both or both now could it be that I'm
wrong well of course yeah there's no
limit to uh even great minds even
Einstein was wrong reputedly and I want
to go there next um so regardless of
what you feel about stepen uh Stephen uh
about Roger penrose's uh conformal
cyclic cosmology that violates the
second law of Thermodynamics um he's
written a book about that I have it over
here cycles of time um in the end it
seems destined that the Universe in any
case will be dying of of a different
type of entropic death the heat death um
what will be left in in your mind what
is the most likely endgame for the
universe just an infinite tenuous void
of black holes forever emitting talking
radio what do you see as the ultimate
long game and and please everybody out
there keep paying your taxes because
this is going long into the future the
thing that I find most
interesting to say it's convincing I
think I was too strong but the thing
that I find most uh interesting is this
idea of Eternal
inflation of Andre Lind and other people
who
uh their picture of what happens with
the universe is it does tend to recycle
itself but not in the same way uh that
uh not in the deterministic way that um
Roger
imagines but that fluctuations take
place fluctuations take place these
fluctuations one version of them are
called colan duta
instantons which cause the universe to
make transitions to other other types of
environments and uh and this just goes
on endlessly forever and
ever and constantly renewing itself to
some extent and potentially that might
be right but I think the real the
real I think I probably should just say
I don't
know I asked you before we began we
began is it okay if you ask me a
question and I say I don't know and you
said yes it's okay so yeah I I I think I
don't know I don't think anybody knows
there are some things which are just
plain inconsistent with the laws of
physics as we know it I think violating
the second law of Thermodynamics is not
a good thing but there are a lot of
ideas out there maybe all of them
violate the laws of physics that would
be a good thing not because I think the
laws of physics are violated but as we
discover that they violate the laws of
physics well we can throw them
away yeah so that helps us winow down
the the field um yeah yeah you talk a
lot in the Cosmic Landscape about the
Multiverse as a a sort of a really a
pmic all in a good way argument against
this anthropic or fine tuning can you
explain why does that bother you because
I feel like the anthropic principle in
some sense your colleague Andre Lind who
who I know wait I I'm I'm an advocate of
the anthropic no no I'm sorry but but uh
right so people like Andre Lind will use
that and say uh he's been quoted as
saying things like why should there be
only one Universe in other words that
it's almost more natural in his mind and
he says almost that he has faith that
there should be other universes um what
what do you what do you make Andre Andre
is an incredibly brilliant physicist he
also has a bit of a spiritual side to it
it's not a religious it's not a
conventional religious side but uh I
don't know quite if the word is
spiritual or idealistic and so forth my
interest in the anthropic idea in the
Multiverse is much more hard-nosed than
that there are three things which uh
would push me in that direction let's
see if I can remember them the first is
that the universe is known to be very
very much bigger than the part we can
see that's from the flatness of the
universe it's like the it's like the
Earth we know it's very very big because
it looks very flat if we're standing in
the middle of a field someplace and we
look out all we can see is a mile in
every direction we could say oh the
Earth may be no bigger than a mile in
every direction but no no no that's not
right it's so damn flat that it must be
much bigger than that same with the
universe so we know it's enormously big
we know this fact about the cosmological
constant it's absurdly small and it
appears to be very very fine
tuned okay and we know that these
Eternal in the the inflationary idea
works very well we know those those
three things and they tend to lead the
equations themselves of trying to
combine those things
together oh we know something else we
also know that this is a string theory
fact the string theory facts are not as
reliable as other things why because it
may not be the right physics but it
seems to produce a vast vast number of
different solutions of its own equations
meaning a vast vast number of different
varieties of
possibilities if you take all those
things together the fine-tuning of the
cosmological constant the fact that
inflation made the universe enormously
big Way Way Beyond what we can
see and uh and the large number of
possibilities inherent in string theory
it's kind of natural to say maybe the
universe is much bigger and more diverse
than the region we can see it's natural
it fits with the equations once we
accept that that it's much much bigger
and more diverse than we can see then it
becomes natural to say well why is the
universe like it is it's like it is
because we live in the kind of region
that will support life we don't ask that
why don't we ask the same question and
get all exercised about the anthropic
principle when it comes to living on the
surface of the earth why do we live on
the surface of the Earth is the Earth is
very fine-tuned it happens to be very in
a very narrow range of
temperatures and environment why what's
going on there why is it so fine tuned
well the stupid answer is that if it
weren't so fine-tuned we wouldn't be
here to ask the question so I find that
more or less convincing of a
convincingly logical line of
reasoning the the the people who dismiss
it tend to dismiss it on what I think of
is not scientific grounds one of my
friends will tell will tell you and it's
a good friend will tell you that's a bad
idea because it will encourage the young
people not to ask for other Solutions of
the problem now that's not a scientific
answer that's a cultural sort of
political
answer
um and I don't know a good scientific
argument against the
Multiverse anthropic idea I think Paul
steinhardt would argue if you were on
the call that uh that you know it's it's
sort of the end of the scientific method
since I remember when we participated I
participated in the bicep 2 announcement
see that's not a scientific argument
that's a political and a cultural
argument it's the end of baloney who how
do we know how science well let me give
you an example Lenny so what happened
was with bicep we got uh we we made the
announcement it was there was a video at
Stanford with Andre and my friend
Shaolin quo is's your colleague there
and then there was a press conference at
Harvard and then the same day I had uh I
had reports of people from uh The
Discovery Institute which is not the
Discovery Channel this is a a pro-
religion mostly Christian site saying
this proves God exists because it's
inexplicable otherwise and then I had
Lawrence Krauss on the other hand saying
also certain Nobel prizes await because
this Pro removes the need for
Supernatural Shenanigans so that you can
have both sides and furthermore when we
said uh when we made the announcement it
wasn't clear exactly what the level of
the tensors to scaler ratio was you know
there's always some uncertainty but
there was no single model that could
predict it and this brings me back to
the landscape that you've uh really
popularized and and I think it's very
healthy to discuss these things so one
thing that's always confused me if I
change the vacuum um energy level the
vacuum vev level in our region of the
universe by 0.1 electron volts that
doesn't change change the law of of uh
universal gravitation it doesn't change
the speed of light Etc why is it that
just the mere existence of the landscape
with 10 to the 500 different vacuum
States why does that mean that we have
different laws of physics I could see
different constants but why would the
laws of physics depend on the vev in a
particular corner of the Multiverse that
of course is an issue of what you mean
by the laws of
physics um the laws of physics as we
know them okay what are the laws of uh
physics on the surface of the earth one
of the laws of physics is if you drop
something from a height it will
accelerate uh what is it the six uh the
acceleration of 9.8 m/ second Square
yeah 9.8 MERS per second that's a
constant of that's a constant of nature
at least it's a constant of nature on
the surface of the Earth but it's also
an environmentally conditioned it's true
for the Earth but it's not true for
other places so I don't think people
would say that the laws of physics are
different on the earth than they are on
the moon because the acceleration of
gravity is
different but until we learn what those
laws of physics are which are Universal
between the Earth and the um and the
moon we have no choice but to say things
are different and the constants of
nature on the Earth are different than
the constants of nature on the on the
moon um it's moral L the same thing
until we learn what those deeper and
overriding rules are that govern
everything all we can say in this
Multiverse picture is that the constants
of the constants of nature that we
normally call the constants of nature
are different in this region from that
region uh nobody wants the laws of
physics themselves the full set of laws
of physics to depend on where you are
and in fact I would say it differently I
would say I think the vision is that
it's not the laws of physics that are
different in the different places it's
the solution to those laws of physics
not the equations themselves but the
solutions of those equations the
solutions might consist of a collection
of constants or collection of
numbers uh they could be one thing could
be another thing but happen to be this
particular thing in our
neighborhood so if you mean by the laws
of physics the the Deep final laws of
physics that we don't know yet I think
everybody would like Andre as well as
everybody else who Advocates this idea
is that those laws should be one set of
laws yeah I I would uh think that would
be most elegant and parsimonious do you
have a few more minutes uh Lenny for a
few final questions a few more yeah so
uh some questions from the audience uh
that are wondering um in the context of
uh uh this is again about younger
Generations so um I want to say oh
somebody's asking about the fascination
with life outside of the earth uh why
why is it that we spend billions of
dollars to look for signatures of water
on mars or whatever what do you think
about the human curiosity or what have
you um uh impels us to spend so much
more on that than say on fundamental
particle physics is it obvious I mean
particles are very remote
things they're too tiny to see too tiny
to
touch um it uh just
uh am I more Cur question am I more
curious about particles which are after
all very boring particles don't have
very much associated with them they have
a a mass and a spin that's about it
they're very very Char and a Char of
charge yeah they have a few parameters
they're Commodities they're commod you
can't talk to them you can't uh am I
more curious about them than I are about
whether there is life in the universe I
would say it's a different kind of
curiosity one I as a
physicist am very interested in
fundamental particles because I think
they may lead to something deeper than
themselves they may lead to an
understanding which is much deeper than
themselves uh but it's very hard to get
at but I as just a uh as a human being
as an ordinary human being I'm terribly
curious about whether there are whether
there's life out there whether I could
communicate with it and so forth so I
find it very easy to understand why
people as a whole would be more
interested in life out there than they
would be in these exceedingly dull
objects which are truly stupid they have
no consciousness they dull they're only
interesting in so far as they could
ultimately lead to something much deeper
than themselves uh someone's asking me
your opinions about the simulation
hypothesis and again it's okay if you
don't know or want to comment on it yeah
I don't know um the simulation
hypothesis means what that we live in a
computer yeah that you're basically Sim
you're being simulated I'm being
simulated because AI is going to
increase so rapidly in and according to
Nick bolom and others that the
overwhelming likelihood of life is that
it's all artificial as Max tegmark wrote
about in life 3.0 okay I don't know what
it means to that uh we certainly live in
a world where there are laws of physics
which predict the which predict how
systems EV evolve they have laws the
world has laws those laws could be
thought of as a computer program if you
like uh or is analogous to a to a
computer program computer program that
tells you what happens next a quantum
computer that tells you if the state of
the universe if the state of the
computer is such and such in the next
instance it will be such and such but we
do seem to live in a world with laws the
laws could be thought of as algorithms
for updating what happens next I think
the real question is not whether we live
in such a
world uh where there's an
algorithmic sense of what happens next
but whether it was put there whether it
was put in place with a purpose is there
an intelligence is there a computer
programmer an intelligence who created
it for a purpose that I haven't got the
vaguest
idea was the was the World created by an
agency an intelligence or something that
uh was trying to do a
computation I personally think not but
uh but uh it seems to me could be one of
my uh subscribers is asking a question I
don't fully understand Patrick is asking
about the holiday or holographic I think
he means a holographic Universe
principle was that startling uh to
discover or come upon or invent first of
all do you believe that physics
theoretical physics is invented or
discovered just yes you're uh one word
answer you don't have to go into a deep
well I think it's I I I think it's a
combination of both that's exactly what
Jim Simon Says both yeah it's a
combination of both uh the ways of the
ways of describing and thinking about an
objective fact might might be somewhat
variable from civilization to
civilization they may all be equivalent
and there may be some inventiveness in
describing a way of thinking about
things uh the way mathematics is
described that the equal sign for
example is two horizontal dashes one
over the other that's an
invention in fact even the whole idea of
an equal sign on the left and a right is
an invention on the other hand it's
describing something which we think is
more um objective
than just the uh the pretty pictures
that we used to describe it so I think
the same is true of physics ways of
describing things are human inventions
the things that they're describing
hopefully are not so maybe he means that
uh you know the holographic universe is
connected to this yeah so um uh right so
coming to the end here just a few more
final questions from the audience and
then I have a couple questions I ask all
my all my uh guests and if you'll if
you're indulge me and have some
forbearance I will ask you them as well
uh so what about Consciousness I had
Nome Chomsky on the podcast recently and
I came away uh as I have for my
discussions with him and Sir Roger
basically feeling they don't really know
what Consciousness is and they're all
kind of speculating this Thomas Nagel uh
essay you know and the hard problem it's
really uh hard harder than than maybe
String Theory to verify or move past
what are your thoughts on Consciousness
if any and I realize you're still in
your pajamas so you may not be fully
conscious people like myself tend to
make tremendous fools of themselves when
they start to talk about things that
they know nothing about thinking that
their great expertise at something else
qualifies
them uh okay that being said that being
said speculate away subject matter
expertise yeah okay of course I don't
know I don't know how Consciousness
works I don't know what it is it seems
to be a thing I feel
conscious uh and so I think it's a thing
but my guess is this is just a guess my
guess is the way the root to
understanding it probably lies in
computer science in building machines
which get to be more and more conscious
likee and eventually understanding what
makes one
machine behave conscious likee and the
other machine not beh behave conscious
like of course we could do that with the
human brain you know but we're not going
to go into the human brain dissect it
and Pull Apart its neurons and so forth
we can't do that um I I guess I also
think that Consciousness is something
that we probably can't just the
practicalities of it we probably can't
engineer engineering something means
building an
algorithm uh intentionally to do that my
guess would be it's so complex and so
difficult that the only thing you can do
is evolve it evolve it the way nature
did but evolve it in the computer big
enough computers complex enough
computers computers which interact with
each other maybe eventually we will
begin to understand through computer
science through uh
AI uh and through and it's connection
with neuroscience and its connection
with
Neuroscience perhaps we will begin to
see patterns emerge in what kind of
things exhibit
Consciousness that I would think is the
Hope for eventually understanding it now
that I made a grand fool of myself Let's
uh we'll move on yeah actually none
other than Galileo galile uh speculated
on the nature of of thoughts and uh n
Chomsky calls it the Galileo problem uh
speaking of Galileo he is visiting right
now here in La Hoya really yeah here he
is uh I think we need a a finger puppet
of you and here's one of Carl Sean we'll
get one of you and then we can really
stick it to you Lenny Lenny I want to
ask you what Heroes would you most like
to meet from that are no longer with us
uh who would you like to have a have a
physics conference with as I said in the
very beginning one of the most touching
endearing parts of black Hall war is
that it made me nostalgic for the times
I could get together with my colleagues
and that my young students are missing
out on the cality of of inperson
gatherings if you could have an inperson
Gathering who would you invite uh of a
great phys from the great physicist of
your okay so let me ask who would I like
to have coffee with there are two
particular figures many many but uh but
there are two particular F figures that
have always intrigued me a great deal
one of them is the ancient Greek aristas
aristarchus was way way he's not as
famous as Aristotle but he was far more
of a greater scientist he was the
greatest scientist of the ancient world
by far he was the one who first figured
out out for good
reasons that the heliocentric
theory
um cernus recognized that and quotes him
but he figured out so many brilliant
things that uh sort of was semi- lost to
history because his writings disappeared
I would love to talk to
aristarchus and see what he thinks about
how things evolved after him okay he
might have been a very boring man who
knows but there is one person that has
always not just fascinated me but I I
sort of feel close to in some and that's
Michael
Faraday Michael Faraday was of course he
he had this
pictorial way of thinking that I find
very close to my own way of thinking
closing your eyes and visualizing he
visualized the lines of flux magnetic
fields electric Fields but he also had
something that I admire tremendously an
ability to explain and a desire to
explain to the general public what
science was about I don't know if you've
ever read his Christmas lectures yes his
Christmas his Christmas lectures to to
The Working Man basically on how
electricity and things work a
marvelous marvelous expository um and he
knew very little formal math right yes
he knew very little formal math but he
had this immense ability to visualize
how nature worked and uh so Michael far
was somebody who has been a hero for me
and maybe that is Lenny a segue that
will get uh some resolution to your um
uh dis displeasure or propensity not to
give advice maybe the advice is to
follow these people or at least learn
about them I feel like if I met a
painter I would say uh you want to be a
painter okay paint Monae paint every
piece that Monae and picu ever painted
and you'll be pretty good and that's
what you do in the theoretical minimum
which is a wonderful segue thanks
thaning I'm hurting myself on the back
by patting myself on the back the
theoretical minimum I'm recommending
that to a very brilliant he's actually
the son of Eric Weinstein I'll get into
that some other time but he's a
brilliant 15-year-old kid and my course
of education for him and tutoring him
somewhat is that I want him to go
through the theoretical minimum and go
through those books I think he'll come
out with this wonderful uh exposure to
the foundations and it's not pure
mathematical there's mathematics but
there's also your love of teaching comes
through and I'm going to put links to
all your great lectures on online I want
to finish if you'll indulge me with a
little more forbearance L three more
questions and then I'll let you go back
to bed so Camron vafa is coming on the
show next week as I said and uh I'll I
don't know did you fix any of his
faucets or toilets back no no Kum is
much younger than me a little older than
me yeah he has this wonderful book
called puzzles to unlock the universe
and in it he talks about his favorite
puzzles and and one of them being the um
the icing model he basically goes
through what is the icing model and why
it's so interesting and it brings up
spontaneous symmetry breaking I wonder
what do you have a favorite puzzle do
you have a way of thinking about um the
you know things that is purely for maybe
Amusement but like solving a puzzle once
you solve it you want to go back and do
it again the answer must be yes but I
but they've caught me unaware so go on
to the next one because I can't think of
a quick answer to that I think
Michaelson uh the great Michaelson said
something like uh all experimentalists
are are puzzle solvers because they're
just like little kids they want to go
back and redo the puzzle and and I
always point out that physicists are
like like kids because they love solving
puzzles they're very curious they don't
play well with others they fight they're
jealous they they have all these Petty
emotions it's interesting as a as a
young person I loved solving puzzles you
know I loved solving you know semi
mathematical logical puzzles and things
like that as as I got
older I I sort of lost interest in it
and I think that's because everything I
did was puzzle solving and
and yeah that's the same reason I don't
read much science fiction because yeah
even though I'm at the Arthur C Clark
Center for human imagination I am uh uh
Duty bound to do it okay final three
questions I ask all my guests on the
into the impossible podcast um so
there's a concept of what's called an
ethical will and actually Alfred Nobel
uh it's actually a Jewish concept you
know that from your Decades of Torah
study as a as a young man yeah right so
it's called a Zava and it comes from
Genesis so we won't get into the to the
the Theology of it all but uh but the
but the point is that people leave
ethical Wills actually Barack Obama has
an ethical will you can find it online
and it's what you'd want to give away to
to the Future to in posterity not
Material will so Alfred Nobel all wanted
to recognize great inventions and
discoveries but he also did so wanted to
do so for the benefit of all mankind is
there anything that you would want to
leave as as an ethical uh will to your
not only to your biological children
grandchildren great-grandchildren but to
your
uh to your ideological children of which
I count myself as a member that's a hard
question we're in a situation right now
which is so fraught
with lack of ethical standards and I not
among everybody of course but among some
people
um oh boy I don't have a I don't have an
answer to that the only thing I can say
is um if you are if you care at all
about the world you've got to speak out
that's phenomenal got you've got you've
got to speak out and you've got to
say clearly what you stand for and what
you believe in and I know I'm talking
about political
things and you know as well as I do how
fraud things are and how dangerous the
world is
how and I would want my descendants both
intellectual and
biological to know that I did speak out
and that I did um
oppose what I consider evil tendencies
in our society I think you know what I'm
talking about I don't have to spell it
out yeah and um fair enough you know I
don't think I hate to break it to you
but you have many many biblical Notions
because that's the actual quote is set
set too you shall pursue justice justice
with all your might that's really what
you're saying and you and you've spoken
about that on many occasions and I you
know I think one of the uh great traits
that you exhibit we'll get to in the
question after this one and that's your
courage but before we get there you've
seen the movie 2001 of Space Odyssey I
hope I did I could not figure it out but
I enjoyed it so there's a lot of
mysterious baffling things in that movie
including these weird ominous monoliths
these black objects placed on the
Savannah of Africa later on the surface
of the moon and um I think of them as
time capsules meant to be found when
humanity is mature enough to appreciate
the lessons encapsulated within this
billion year old time capsule what would
Leonard susin put on a time capsule
guaranteed to last for a billion years
ask me something easier I it's the last
two questions you can't you can't say I
don't know to the final three questions
it's my only rule well the answer is I
haven't thought of it and that's a big
big question it's a big big question and
requires thought and I haven't thought
about it that's what I would answer you
don't have a favorite equation or
discovery of yours that you String
Theory the foundational equations of
string theory well foundational
equations of string theory won't mean
anything to a civilization which has
lost its knowledge of Newton's equations
so okay so there would be no point in
that if a thousand years or 10,000 or
20,000 years civilization goes through
some upheavals and manages to lose a
large amount of the knowledge that it
now has what would I want it to remember
so it could get started again not
necessarily as Fineman said you know he
he was asked a similar question he said
that the world is made of atoms which
are indivisible you know what what what
fact of of physics have you do you find
most kind of worthy of preservation not
not to reboot Society 2.0 but but more
most remarkable discovery that the human
mind has come up with or discovered I am
very partial to the second law of
Thermodynamics very partial to it beyond
that quantum entanglement how about that
quantum entanglement fair enough and
actually that D Tails nicely to your uh
to your fascination with with entropy
and the marriage of the two of them
surprisingly fascinatingly at the
surface of a black hole the stretched
Horizon of black exactly last question
Lenny before I uh let you go out for
your cup of coffee with your wife um so
we've gotten into the future both in
what you'd leave for Humanity kind of as
an ethical will and even discussed what
would happen on a time capsule or what
you'd put on a time capsule but I want
to ask you now going backwards in time
so Sir Arthur C Clark had all these
famous laws the first one is any
sufficiently advanced technology is
indistinguishable from Magic his second
law states that for every expert there's
an equal and opposite
expert and his his third law is the only
way of discovering the limits of the
possible is to venture a little way past
them into the impossible and that's how
I got the name for this podcast it's
called into the impossible for that very
reason what thing about your life
mystified you or did you think was
impossible and then thanks to your
courage was eminently doable because you
had the you had the vision and the
intensity to go into the impossible well
I'm not sure it quite answers the
question but there's a there's a
quotation that I've always liked and
admired because I think it really does
reflect things about the way I think and
it's a quotation of the famous
detective you know which detective Mr
Sherlock Sherlock Holmes I presume right
now how the hell did it go when you have
eliminated
all that is
impossible whatever remains must be the
truth I do you do you do you know the
precise once you have once you eliminate
the impossible whatever remains no
matter how improbable must
the truth Arthur conand Doyle no that
was Sherlock Holmes yes yeah I
know no no you can't give that to AR cor
it's Sherlock Holmes I'll cite that his
his H index is is too low I always felt
a lot of my life went that way that I my
life I mean my scientific life that I
try I was up against puzzles which I
didn't understand
and I kept looking for Solutions looking
for Solutions looking for Solutions
always in the back of my mind was that
was that one crazy
solution that I was afraid of because it
was just too
unlikely but
eventually everything else failed and
you realized it was all it was left the
holographic principle is a particular
example of that now of course that was
not only me that was also
har but um that I had sensed that long
before but just kept thinking that's too
crazy that the world is a is a kind of
hologram and just pushing against the
problem in particular the problem that
Steph Hawking had raised and looking for
this solution that solution and
eventually I realized that's that's got
to be it there's nothing else
left and so I always admire
Sherlock's uh
quote did that answer the question
probably had nothing to do with a
question but it did it did in fact it
did me better because now I've got
another question to ask my future guest
I'm GNA ask Shelly that tomorrow I'm
going to say none other than sir Leonard
suskin so I want to remind uh folks that
tomorrow I'll have on shelle glashow
please send me questions uh for him I've
already gotten one from our esteemed
guest uh Professor Leonard suskin and in
your honor Leonard tomorrow is the
Leonid meteor show so we arranged for
that so when you look up from Northern
California know that I'm thinking about
you and I will send you some meteorite
someday as I do to my some of my
subscribers to my newsletter these are
actual meteorites space dust from 4.2
billion years old uh some collected from
the Leonid meteor shower in honor of
Leonard suskin I want to thank you
Leonard uh so much you've been uh a
wonderful guest and you've been an
inspiration and even though you can't
remember meeting me we did meet and I
can now say I met a living Lenny Legend
and I want to thank you so much for
going into the impossible and wish you
all the best and I hope we'll stay in
touch